[A] We're living in a tumultuous time period
[A] of uncertainty, macroeconomic and otherwise.
[A] The world's kind of chaos right now.
[A] There are people that have difficulty
[A] maneuvering through this stuff.
[A] What are some of the ways,
[A] words of wisdom or otherwise,
[A] that have helped you navigate the difficulties in life?
[B] The tourists are here when the market's good
[B] and the builders are here when the market's bad.
[B] So I mean, Stellar has been around for over a decade.
[B] There's been so many boom cycles, bust cycles.
[B] I believe in the technology.
[B] The speculative prices can come and go.
[B] I want to make it such that folks can send
[B] US dollars to anyone in the world
[B] for a fraction of a penny in less than a second. Right?
[B] The price of Bitcoin doesn't affect that vision.
[B] If you're a gambler, gamble.
[B] But if you just want to build cool stuff,
[B] then just head down and build.
[A] Head down and build.
[A] Let's fucking go, man.
[A] That was awesome.